but we begin sadly tragically with
another school shooting this time in
Denver Police say two School
administrators were wounded Yesterday by
a 17 year old student who's being
searched after previous misbehavior
officials say that student has since
been found dead right after the shooting
parents gathered and braced one another
and confronted the city's mayor and
police chief
I think
you could hear the pain in the rage and
their voices Kennedy cook with our CBS
Denver station kcnc is following all
this for us Kennedy good morning
good morning now one of the
administrators that was shot during the
incident was released from the hospital
and the other was listed in critical
condition but even before yesterday
shooting students and parents expressed
concern over the perceived security
concerns as well as constant lockdowns
here at East High School and their fears
and frustrations culminated yesterday as
shots rang at the beginning of the
school day
frightening moments for more than 2500
students and staff at East High School
in Denver yesterday after a shooting on
campus
police say two staff members Gerald
Mason and Eric Sinclair were conducting
a routine pat down search of 17 year old
Austin Lyle when a handgun was
discovered in his possession that's when
police say the student shot both men
this particular student actually had a
safety plan that was in place where they
were to be searched at the beginning of
the school day every day they had been
searched previously to today and had
never had a weapon on them before school
officials have not provided a reason why
the teenager required Pat Downs other
than citing his past Behavior nor have
they said how many other students are on
a similar safety plan this is common for
all schools in all districts
part of what we have in terms of making
sure that we can support the needs and
behavioral needs of students at this
point nobody feels safe student
action no more meetings No More Words
earlier this month student body
president Hadley hagasath led a massive
student March to the Colorado State
Capitol demanding stricter safety rules
after a 16 year old student Luis Garcia
was shot and killed while sitting in a
car outside the school we marched we
walked
I thought I did everything I could have
done as a student I talked with senate
members
and it's not enough
East High School will be closed for the
rest of the week and the school
superintendent said that there will be
two armed officers posted at the school
throughout the rest of the school year
even though the school did vote to
remove those officers back in 2020. Yale
Kennedy cook of kcnc TV we thank you
very much that one student had it right
it's not enough